[Music]  okay some of my best work I think what  you guys think it's good but how about  we add more dinosaurs oh I can't I  really add more dinosaurs it's are you  aren't you an intern yes I am  oh go time we got to upload this trailer  yeah I've got this guy guys did it  suddenly just become ominous here get  your phone yeah thank you could have  just use the flashlight app after you  guys  [Music]  you're gonna go get out here  I gotta go you gotta go you gotta go  guys settle rooms this way let's go on  three three two  it's UNIX system I do this at some point  you're gonna turn this back into my  phone right magic words  can I get Instagram  Zak get that trailer on a floppy disk  [Music]  Oh Michael  wait so it was a cat that made the  dinosaur sound and poor apart the  monitor something seems kind of  [Music]  [Music]